please stand for the chairman of Planet
District Council
previously said everyone
here we are
all right now
right well thanks everyone for coming
despite the cold snap and I can assure
you it's as cold up there up here as it
probably is down there
that's right uh good evening members and
officers of the council members of the
press and public I welcome you to this
meeting of the council
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the building via the emergency
exits
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film a
meeting
and I don't see anyone
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst meeting is in
progress
good agenda item one apologies for
absence apologies have been received
from counselor Curry councilor Coleman
cook councilor Whitehead councilor
farens councilor Parsons Council Wright
counselor ratican are there any other
apologies
Linda Potts thank you any others
I don't see any others have we got this
great
a general item two minutes of the
previous meetings
I move the minutes of the council
meeting held on the 24th of February
2022 be approved and signed as a correct
record with the vice chair please second
agreed to members agree
thank you agenda item 3 announcements I
have two announcements
first I'd like to congratulate councilor
Nixie on her recent election to the
nether Court Ward councilor Nixie there
yes thank you very much I'm happy to uh
represent Liz green over here thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
also as a reminder two members please
note that the extraordinary council
meeting scheduled for the next Tuesday
will start the slightly earlier than
usual time of 6 pm
so if we all make a note of that we can
all be here
agenda item 4 Declarations of Interest
are there indeclarations of interest
this evening
and I don't see anyone indicating
a gender item
six
no gender item five
excuse me petitions
no new petitions have been received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
12.
agenda item six moving on to questions
from the press and public
three questions have been received from
members of the public in accordance with
Council procedure rule number 13.
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question
got the questioner please only state the
name of the cabinet member to whom their
question is be put and read out the
exact wording of the question that they
are submitted to the council
gender item therefore 6A question number
one from a member of the public
regarding the identification of
Brownfield sites for housing
developments
uh hoping to be pleased to welcome Miss
McCourt to the meeting
could you please uh please make a way to
the microphone Ms McCourt
shall start
yeah okay
we all know that the algorithm for
projected housing figures is wrong
but what is TDC doing to press further
on the identification of Brownfield
sites for developments rather than
digging up our Prime farmland
why are Council officers not being
proactive in approaching owners of
Brownfield sites and if it is not normal
practice then will Council officers look
towards changing this practice
particularly in light of the fact that
we need our farmland for food growth
production and not houses that we do not
need
[Applause]
thank you very much Miss McCourt I call
upon the leader to respond
thank you chair and thank you Mr court
for your question
the test for site allocations in
government guidance are available
are availability suitability and
achievability
which means that a landowner have to be
willing for the sites to be bought
forward they must be suitable in
planning terms across a range of matters
and be capable of delivery within the
plan period
the call for sites is only one part of
the process of identifying land for
residential and other developments
another part of the process is to carry
out desk and site surveys to identify
other sites including Brownfield sites
that meet the site allocation criteria
above in cases where sites meet the
criteria above the landowners are
contacted to see what their intentions
are for the sites in question this
approach has been standard for many
years
such work was carried out for the
adopted plan and is being undertaken at
the moment to inform the local Plan
update
and I can assure you that I actually
spent Sunday afternoon looking at our
Brownfield site
list and I will be reviewing it
regularly as I do with the with the
planning so that we can identify if
anything is actually going to be
suitable for the overall criteria that
is needed to be met so I appreciate your
question and hopefully that is an answer
for you
thank you very much councilor Ashby
the gender item 6B question number two
from a member of the public Also
regarding the identification of
Brownfield sites for housing
developments I'm pleased to welcome Miss
Brown to the meeting could you please
make your way to the microphone Miss
Brown
becoming increasingly anxious about the
current and future food security because
of that Region's importance in the
global supply of grains such as wheat
allowing the development of prime
productive Farmland in thanet that also
grows wheat will decrease our ability to
grow food in this country adding to the
Reliance on food imports we already
import 40 to 50 percent of our food in
light of this and the government's
emphasis on using Brownfield for
development instead of greenfields can
you please tell me are you required to
actively search for Brownfield sites and
if you are what are you doing to fulfill
this requirement
thank you very much indeed Miss Brown
now I call upon the leader councilor
Ashby again you can elaborate here on
this one thank you chair and thank you
for your question
um as it is obviously very similar to
the previous question
um I will reiterate again the um the
test for the sites is the availability
suitability ability and achievability I
do appreciate that
um obviously the Ukraine well and Russia
at that point are regarded as the Bread
Basket of Europe and I think the
situation out there is is very alarming
um part of the process of identifying
land for residential and other
development is to carry out the desktop
surveys as I previously said and it
should be noted there is not currently
and I will stress currently
an absolute protection for agricultural
land in the government Guidance the
national planning policy framework says
where significant land for agricultural
land is demonstrated to be necessary
areas of poorer quality should be
preferred to those of higher quality but
maybe with the war and maybe the
pressure that
um we can put on the government then
there will be serious reconsideration
regarding the use of our agricultural
land so you can rest assured that um
this Council uh
um will be asking the government to
constantly ask the government to
reconsider whether or not they need to
adjust their policy their framework so
um that's basically the situation at the
moment but your your question is
acknowledged and understood thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby I have a question number three
from a member of the public regarding
the maintenance of public toilet from a
Mr rain white who may not be here Mr
Wayne Wright are you here this evening
Mr rainwright does not appear to be here
Mr Wainwright will get a written answer
to his question
so you're off the hook councilor cup
agenda item seven questions from members
of the council now this evening I have
seven questions have been received from
members of the council please note that
the time allowed for consideration of
questions from Members shall not exceed
30 minutes I ask members to be succinct
as possible
agenda item 7A question number from one
from a member regarding the future of
thanet Heritage theaters I call upon
councilor Gregory
thank you chair
many have found its Heritage of theater
venues have in the past attracted large
audiences and Driver closed now derelict
due to lack of routine maintenance or
are imminent to shunt possibly lost to
thanet and its visiting Community
forever what plans does TDC have for
Westcliff Concert Hall in Ramsgate the
Granville theater in Ramsgate the
theater Royal Margate and the Winter
Gardens Margate for them to be restored
to their former glory
thank you councilor Gregory and Council
Pugh you're on the hook instead
I am chair thank you and I apologize to
anyone that's disappointed that it's
going to be me
um but it is thank you councilor Gregory
uh for your question I had the following
uh to share the Granville theater on
Victoria Parade Ramsgate was built in
the 1940s originally as a theater with a
cinema screen added later the theater is
owned by the council but it's been
managed by leaseholders since 1998. the
building was leased to Granville theater
limit in 2007 but that Arrangement came
to an end in November 2020 when the
lease was surrendered the building has
been closed since the start of the
national covid-19 lockdown in 2020.
uh the building was last surveyed in
2017. and this highlighted an extensive
list of necessary maintenance with a
total cost estimated at 152 000 pounds
in addition to this the roof is in a
particularly poor condition and repairs
are estimated to cost around 250 000
pounds
in July 2021
members of Planet District council's
cabinet agreed to transfer the Granville
theater into the hands of a community
organization if a viable bid was put
forward in October 2021 we invited
Community groups to express their
interest in
pause interested in bidding for the
Freehold of the building and the right
to continue to operate commercial
property agents will shortly be offering
the building on the open market inviting
proposals that reflect the status
condition and future use of the property
eligible Community groups including the
Kent film foundation will have the
opportunity to bid alongside commercial
organizations in relation to the West
Westcliff Hall in Ramsgate it is in
private ownership and therefore not a
matter for TDC that we can comment on
Beyond saying Beyond sharing a view that
we are very much want to see it
developed positively the theater role
forms part of the Margate Town deal and
within the town deal scaling creative
production and skills intervention there
is a two million pound allocation for
the theater Royal project the town
investment plan states that this will be
used to improve the theater role and the
surrounding environment to create a new
hub for theatrical production
um in relation to the Winter Gardens
there's a Margate Town Deal Board which
is our central government for Revenue
funding to support the market Winter
Gardens in the development of a
long-term plan
as a result there is now 300 000 pounds
of Revenue funding allocated for the
Winter Gardens project
the funding will enable a piece of work
which will provide a Clear Vision and
detailed project delivery plan for the
winter Garden's future including how it
can operate in tandem with the other
Leisure venues and key Heritage Assets
in Margate featured in the town
investment plan Dreamland and the
theater role
thank you very much councilor Pugh
councilor Gregory do you have a
supplementary
thank you I just I just don't know why
these places
change they seem to get into a state
before anything's done
thank you Council agree about you
counselor Pugh for that
so yes back to you councilor Pugh for
that it's all right Jeff thank you I
appreciate I've already spoken too much
but I've got other questions to answer
later as well so everyone has to get
used to it um thank you councilor
Gregory I completely understand uh your
concern of course we as a council it's
incredibly important it's our priority
to see many of these wonderful assets
restored that's their former glory
um because I'm sure you'll wear as a
council and every one pound of council
tax of residence pay we only receive 12
Pence services are very tight at the
moment
um so unfortunately something's too slip
but what I would say is that it's not
always should not shouldn't always be
the priority of the council to maintain
these buildings and keep them going if
there are Community groups that have the
passion and Flair and the funding
available uh to bring them back to even
better than their former glory
thank you very much indeed councilor
Pugh
gender items 6B question number two from
a member regarding the allocation of a
traveler site I call upon councilor Roth
thank you leader um my question is for a
leader a Travelers issue has been not
going for some times the working party
has been set up for nearly two years to
allocate a place for them can the lead
area show us we will hear the result
very soon thank you
thank you councilor off I called upon
the leader to respond
chair thank you Council
mination should be identified through
the local plan process
the site search and allocation process
for the local planned update is being
undertaken at the moment
the test for site allocations are
availability suitability and
achievability which means that
landowners have to be willing for their
sites to be brought forward they must be
suitable in planning terms across a
ride-range Rockler wide range of matters
and be capable of delivery within the
plan period
no sights sadly have been proposed to
the council specifically for
consideration as Gypsy and traveler
sites which means that the site search
work has to be extended
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby Council Rolfe do you have a
supplementary yeah yes I got a
supplementary question is regarding the
families already in Ramsgate Port
these families their kids are going to
Local Schools some of them they're
registered with GPS and also they help
in our local community especially with
food bank and Council spending money
taking them to court to move them from
there and by moving them from the port
and spending taxpayers money or keep
removing them we're just moving from
there to somewhere else and then they
have to take him to court again to move
them from there can we just leave them
where they are and can the leader tell
us we would be happy to meet up with
interesting party and find a right
solution for these people thank you
thank you Council Ruff uh councilor
Ashby
thank you um chair and thank you
councilor off um
the way that I can help the families the
traveling fraternity and the Gypsy
fraternity is to actually find a
long-term solution for this Council to
provide suitable sites for them to come
and live safely and
um and for their children to attend
schools Etc I can't comment on on the
port situation because at the moment
there are various processes which are
being handled by the senior officers of
this Council of which I cannot get
involved in
but I can confirm and I want to
reiterate that it is my priority in the
time that I have remaining to try and
find a solution to the problem of them
us as a council not having a suitable
stopping and permanent site for for The
Travelers and the gypsies so I can
confirm even this is the latest uh very
hot news because we only had the meeting
this afternoon but Council Joe bayford
and myself met with senior officers of
the council to discuss the recent
Department of leveling up Housing and
Community I wish they wouldn't have such
a long title the 10 million Capital fund
to support local authorities in building
new Transit and permanent traveler sites
I'm very hopeful that our bid will be
submitted by the 13th of June 2020
deadline
[Applause]
and if it is successful which I very
much hope that it is it will be
certainly assist us in providing a
solution for this matter for on a long
term sustainable future thank you
well well done thank you very much
indeed leader councilor Ashby
gender item 7c question number three
from a member regarding the future of
the period toilet a serious issue but
rather mutedly put I call upon counselor
Everett
thank you chair
can counselor cup is the cabinet member
flush away rumors that the future of the
per toilets which provide the main
public conveniences for remsgate main
Sands is in doubt is this conservative
Administration which has no concern no
Ramsgate councilors on its front bench
considering pulling the chain on them
there it was there's the punchline I
call upon councilor cup to respond
thank you chair and thank you Council
Robert it's it's uh it's often as if
there's a broken record on here because
it's worrying that the leader of the
labor group still cannot seem to realize
that the conservative cabinet is here to
work for the whole of thanet not just
the wards that we are counselors for and
clearly it has escaped counter Revere's
attention that his own shallow cabinet
doesn't represent the whole of thanet
but as a Cabinet member working for the
whole of thanet I will of course answer
the main tracks of his question a
decision in the future of the toilets
across the whole District needs to be
taken and we are developing a strategy
to deal with the issue that covers a
range of options and any proposal will
go to the cabinet for decision thank you
chair
thank you very much indeed councilor cut
by see some cut and thrust developing uh
Council area do you have a supplementary
question
this seal over there sorry well of
course the shadow cabinet isn't making
decisions about areas that it doesn't
represent can counselor cup tell us then
um if he was a member of the public who
was caught short in Ramsgate in the
future who found that the council had
closed the pr toilets the council had
closed the Cavendish Street toilets the
council had closed the King George for
six Park toilets and the council had
closed the Ramsgate Cemetery toilets
what they ought to do
thank you councilor Everett back to you
councilor cup
unfortunately I can't answer to
fantasies so I don't know thank you
all right
agenda item 7D question number four from
a member regarding the future of the
grand for theater Ramsgate I call upon
councilor Austin
thank you chair a bit of a theme I'm
afraid counselor Pugh um in the light of
the confusion upset over the future of
Ramsgate Granville theater I'd be
grateful if you could clarify the
current situation the process going
forward and I know you've done some of
this in your helpful responses to
Residents who've expressed concern
understandably you've stressed our need
to ensure best value
sadly Best Value in Ramsgate to date has
consistently been interpreted as sale to
the highest bidder leaving important
buildings like Westcliff Hall the West
Cliff on the cafe and 18 Albert Street
derelict generating significant negative
ongoing value for our residents and for
our visitor economy we're delighted to
see the Granville featured as a clear
Traction in our regeneration team's
recently published landscape future plan
could you please outline the process
we'll follow for this important asset
for now on and explain what we're doing
to ensure the Granville elements of the
Ramsgate future plan can still be
delivered thank you
thank you councilor Austin councilor
Pugh
thank you chair and thank you Council
Austin uh for your question
um as I have covered some of this
already I won't uh go over it all again
but I'm more than happy to provide you
with a full copy of the response so
you've got it for your records
um in July 2021 members of thanic
District council's cabinet agreed to
transfer the Granville theater into the
hands of community organization if a
viable bid was put forward in October
2021 we invited Community groups to
express their interest in bidding for
the Freehold of the building and the
right to continue to operate in we
received a submission from Kent film
Foundation which was considered by a
panel of offices from across the council
the submission was scored in strict
accordance with the Community Asset
transfer policy as a council we have a
duty to our residents to make sure that
any community group that wants to take
on a public building can provide the
evidence that it has the skills and
experience to do so and that the project
is a long-term long-term future that
will benefit The Wider Community
unfortunately the kff submission did not
provide adequate designs or costumes for
the refurbishment of the building and
lacked proof of funding and a realistic
business plan
that doesn't mean that they can't now
bid under the Community right to bid
which I believe they are doing so
commercial property agents will shortly
be offering the building on the open
market inviting proposals that reflect
the status condition and future use of
the property illegible Community groups
including the Kent film foundation will
have the opportunity to bid alongside
commercial organizations
thank you counselor Pugh I call upon
Council Austin do you have a
supplementary Council Austin I do thank
you chair thank you Council Pugh what
I'm concerned about obviously is is what
is going to happen with this building in
the future and obviously that's what
Ramsgate residents are concerned about
you say proposals that reflect the
status condition and future use of the
building is cabinet committed to
ensuring that the future use of this
building is as an entertainment venue as
featured in the ramscape future plan
rather than going to developers like so
many other buildings have in Ramsgate
thank you thank you Costa Council back
to councilor pew
thank you Chan thank you Council Austin
for your supplementary what I would say
is that we as a Cabinet we're in we're
committed to ensure that the best
possible future for the Granville
theater as a building uh continues to
and that's what it has whether that be
you in the hands of a community group or
within a private ownership through the
auction or whatever following the
process
um remains to be seen but our priority
is to ensure that the best possible use
of the building and the best utilization
of the building is is what happens
thank you very much indeed councilor
Pugh agenda item 7e question number five
from a member regarding disabled parking
base now this question is from Council
Whitehead who is not here this evening
therefore she will get an answer in
writing
foreign
agenda item 7f question number six from
a member regarding affordable housing
requirements for Housing Development
again I this is from councilor farence
who again is not here this evening she
too will receive a question the answer
in writing
uh
agenda item 7g question number seven
from a member regarding the council's
response to public concern about the
future of the Granville theater Ramsgate
I call upon councilor Crittenden
councilor Crittenden
thank you yes you're on the stage again
um has the leader noted the extent of
concern in Ramsgate and Beyond about the
future would you put your microphone on
sorry it is
can I come down here
has the leader noted the extent of
concern in Ramsgate and Beyond about the
future of the Granville theater
what steps is she taking to address this
concern and reassure the public that her
Administration is listening to what
local people obviously want thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed councilor
Chris and sorry to interrupt you it's
just I couldn't hear you very well
um but councilor Hewitt I think you
heard that over to you
thank you Jen thank you councilor
Christensen I apologize you haven't got
the leader you've got me
um but I will I will try and do my best
we are almost matching to be fair so
it's almost the same you look alike um
leader
oh I love it um the leaving cabinet have
very much listened to the views of local
people regarding the Granville Theater
which is why in July 2021 the cabinet
agreed to transfer the Grand Theater
into the handsome Community organization
um if the Bible bid was put forward of
course I'm not going to now uh cancel
and go over uh the same response that I
provided I'm more than happy to provide
you with a full copy of this as well
um but everything is within strict
accordance with our Community Asset
transfer policy
um of course again we have a duty to
Residents to make sure that any
community group that wants to take on
the public building can provide the
evidence that it has the skills and
experience to do so and that the the
project has a long-term future that will
benefit the community
foreign
the Granville theater is a location that
holds fond memories for many local
people and I recognize that the cabinet
recognizes that and I understand the
strength of feeling and the concern from
residents about its future
but it is incredibly and it's really
encouraging to see the amount of
positive local support through its
Redevelopment we're committed to
securing the positive future for the
building whatever that may be and we
hope that it will well and it will
benefit the local community for
generations to come and I think that's
an incredibly important thing uh to say
not just to council Christian but to all
councilors here you know there are
difficult decisions that need to be made
this Council owns a lot of assets and
it's important that we don't just sit on
the assets and do nothing and if a
community a community group or a private
individual can do better with assets at
the council owns
um then I'm all for us making that
reality as we have done before whether
it has been a success or not I always
think it's something that we should
explore
thank you councilor pure councilor
Crittenden do you have a supplementary
uh yes please
will the leader confirm
she will deliver the Granville to the
benefit of the local community and I
hear what you said
um enable in order to reassure the
residents it will not end up as flats or
a supermarket which is their greatest
concern or yet another failed derelict
site which is what comes back to other
questions thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Crittenden and now you address that's
the leader but I got a feeling cancer
Pugh might be responding
thank you chair you're right you know
I'm happy to step in for the leader and
and take the hits fine
um Council thank you for your
supplementation I do appreciate that
um I think it's important to say that
within any transfer of an asset such as
the Granville whether it be to a
community group or to a private
individual there's certain things within
the sale that we can stipulate now if
that means that there's a stipulation
that it won't can't be used for
residential development or something
like that I'm more than happy to commit
now that they'll that will do that I
don't think that's necessarily an issue
um
you know I think it's a difficult
situation but what I would say is that
there are some assets going way back you
know some iconic builders in Ramsgate
that are now not what they were I think
the former Iceland used to be a big
Cinema years ago you know it's not
anymore but it's now got a use for the
community that's completely different
um I'd be interested to see a
supermarket try and turn the Granville
into a Tesco's or waitrose but
um
you know that remains to be seen
um but I do hear what you're saying and
of course we're committed to try and
bring the best outcome for the Granville
for The Wider community
thank you very much indeed councilor
Pugh
gender item 8 motioned on notice no
motions on notice have been received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
three so I therefore move on to agenda
item nine the leaders report I therefore
call upon the leader counselor Ashby to
present her report
firstly I would like us all to take a
moment to reflect on the situation in
Ukraine and the pain and suffering one
power crazed man can cause to so many
men women and children
I think we must all think about this
when we're fighting our local battles
there is
um a big there is a big battle going on
somewhere that is outside of our control
but it we must all remember how things
can escalate out of control
it is enormous concern and we stand in
solidarity with the Ukrainian people
here in sanit we are committed to
playing our part in the National effort
to welcome and support Refugee families
the government has announced that local
authorities will be provided with
funding to deliver the wrap around
support needed by refugees coming into
the UK but at this stage it is unknown
when or how many ukrainians might be
arriving in Spanish
in the meantime we are working with our
partners in the Kent resilience forum
and government to identify how support
can be provided to include accommodation
safeguarding checks translation services
access to health services and education
final Ramsgate Heritage action Zone
seafront paint Place making is reaching
the end of its Fifth and final year the
its focused on Ramsgate seafront from
west to east Cliffs and along the
promenades we'll explore the past
present and future recording what
Ramsgate seafront means to the local
community today and for time to come
the establishment of the Margate
creative Land Trust received the good
news from the government that the plan
has now been approved the aim of the
trust is support is to support and grow
creative practices enabling local people
to have opportunities to participate in
the Arts
trustees are being sought to fill the
roles to help provide ongoing strategic
Direction and critical challenge
Jackie Bakers in Ramsgate saw our first
ever Community tree planting day the
event was part of the Queen's green
canopy project and over 40 residents
attended to plant a tree with Cabinet
member councilor George cupp Deputy
Lieutenant Clive Stevens councilor Pat
Moore
and as Deputy as Deputy leader of
Ramsgate along with numerous other
councilors
our Open Spaces team also planted seven
larger trees that add to the 35 trees
already planted by the community
earlier in the month councilor Bob
bayford Cabinet member for climate
change attended a visit by Lord Devon
and the government and the government's
climate change committee to King George
V Park in Garland this was part of the
national tour to see firsthand what
different parts of the country are doing
to achieve ambitious climate ambitious
climate goals and we were delighted that
Lord Devon chose to visit us here in
thanet
speaking at a meeting in Maidstone later
that day where I was in attendance Lord
Devin said how impressed he was at how
the various parties have come together
to make the suds project such a success
various digital technology projects have
been launched showing thanet Leading The
Way Forward on Resident and business
Communications there is the green
tourism toolkit a new toolkit to support
local businesses with ideas to help them
to become more environmentally friendly
and showcase the district as a
responsible tourism destination
then there is the online waste portal a
new digital waste portal for residents
to access details of all their waste and
recycling services online
it will provide real-time information
about bin collections allow residents to
report any issues via the portal without
needing to complete a form bin
collection calendars and subscription
signs up to this council's Garden
Greenway Services
finally the other portal to speak of is
the open portal which is a new and
secure online portal enabling residents
and businesses to see and manage their
council tax and business rates accounts
housing benefit claims payment history
notification letters and much more all
in one place
they will enable viewing of up-to-date
account information checking of your
balances review payments apply for a
single person's discount update contact
details report a change of address
switch to paperless billing and set up a
direct debit unfortunately unlike the
energy companies we can't give a
discount for uh paperless billing
the fourth edition of our action against
litter newsletter was published online
giving details of the seventh annual
Great British spring clean three-day
district-wide spring clean event which
takes place during the first week of
April
so coming up I believe next week TDC
councils and staff will be taking part
along with our district-wide all year
round volunteer litter picking Army
which we are most grateful for all their
efforts that they do continuously
included in the news was a reminder of
the great work of plastic free
broadstairs the Palm Bay primary school
and Enterprise Learning Alliance pupils
who were awarded certificates for
learning for litter picking activities
TDC has now awarded 60 certificates to
pupils across Thanos
ahead of next year's elections we are
hosting a become a counselor event to
encourage people living and working in
thanet to find out more about the
district council role it is important
that our groups within the council
chamber reflect the community it serves
and it is important to encourage people
from across than its diverse communities
to come forward and to help make a
difference to people's lives
finally residents in Margate will have
received a leaflet through the door
about margate's bid to become a Town
Council unlike other Town fan
unlike other than towns Margate is a
charter town and the trustees have
launched a bid for a Town Council
people registered to vote in the Seven
Margate Wards are eligible to sign a
supporting petition and should enough
signatures be reached it will trigger a
community governance review by the
council thank you for your time
listening
thank you very much indeed leader I call
upon the councilor Everett to comment on
or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report councilor Everett thank
you chair I'd like to thank the leader
for a report and I'm sure that we all
share the same concern about what is
happening in Ukraine
I know that there are residents in Fanny
who are ready and willing to house
refugees and I hope the bureaucracy
won't get in the way of their generosity
and I'm also sure that those who do come
will contribute to our community as have
those who came before them
I am of course in full support of the
become a counselor initiative and I'm
delighted as I'm sure the leader is that
we in the labor party are able to help
one local resident become a counselor
here last week
welcome councilor Nixie
I note that the press release highlights
a need for councilors from thanex
Eastern European and roma communities
but there are of course many groups that
are underrepresented in this Council and
some that are well represented including
I'm pleased to say Charlton athletic
supporters but it may not be the top
priority for residents
seriously we need to think how we
motivate people from all sections of the
community to become councilors
regardless of party or football
Allegiance as I said in paying tribute
to the late Mary King last month we
needed more counselors from relatively
deprived backgrounds to make sure their
voice is heard in this chamber and I
don't know but I wonder how many current
members live in social housing for
example
we also need more younger people
I don't think we encourage either with a
basic allowance of 4570 pounds parents
of young children often working hard to
keep their heads above water usually
can't afford the time it takes to do the
job of being a counselor properly if it
prevents them earning and of course
there are issues of affordability for
the council and of course it is about
public service but it often seems to me
that some of us are selective in their
interpretation of the role of the market
perhaps fewer councilors would help us
in that respect
councilor Whitehead isn't able to be
here tonight because she's recovering
from covid but I know she would make the
point that April is autism acceptance
month and that diversity takes many
forms
what we can all do to encourage new
people to come forward is to show that
being a councilor matters that what we
do makes a difference and be visible in
our worlds not just on social media or
even mainstream media and also be honest
about the difficult decisions the
council has to make whoever is in
control otherwise we just feed cynicism
I welcome the success of the Margate
creative land trust the community tree
planting initiative at Jackie Bakers and
the forthcoming litter picking events
although I know that this work is
already well underway in Ramsgate
many hands like make light work is the
claim but I think those involved might
dispute that because I know it can be
very hard work
either way it's a real challenge to
maintain our streets and Open Spaces in
this respect throughout the year and we
must continue to challenge the culture
that says it's okay to leave litter in
the first place especially when most of
it isn't biodegradable of course with
our visitor economy it's not just
residents who are responsible
as far as the new digital services are
concerned anything which makes waste
collection more efficient for residents
has my support but mistakes do
inevitably occur and I think the real
test is on the councilor's ability to is
whether the council's ability to respond
when notified of them actually improves
obviously if a service is run on a tight
budget the capacity recover errors is
going to be limited but being told
you've got to wait a week or a fortnight
just adds to the initial frustration
finally on the subject of Margate Town
Council in some ways it's hard in my
business
but I do commend to the good people of
Margate the example of Ramsgate Town
Council and I know that the leader was
at the Ramsgate town meeting last night
to hear how positively RTC is regarded
by those residents present
as the late Peter Campbell would
regularly remind us it is in Ramsgate
and broadstairs and the other parish's
interest for there to be a Margate Town
Council because without it residents
elsewhere will continue to be taxed
twice paying for Margate to receive some
Services through TDC as well as for
those in their own area through the
parish precept
but Margate will also benefit from more
autonomy and opportunity to deliver
hyper local initiatives so I do hope
that local people will support it but of
course if Margate wants a Town Council
as good as RAM Gates ramsgates will have
to give it a labor majority soon
thank you very much for Everett
councilor Ashby you're not going to
dispute too much of that are you
no I think councilor Everett for his
response
um
might struggle a little bit with your
last comment unless to change the
boundaries of course um which um is
always on the cards um thank you for
your comments um if I unless I missed it
there wasn't actually a question in
there but um uh we'll we I like to think
that we you know we are thinking along
the same lines and agree with you that
uh we need to encourage young counselors
um quite proud that I've got some you
know three youngsters sitting here to my
left
[Laughter]
[Applause]
when Bob first became a counselor yes he
was very young but um no um on a serious
note it is a problem for for young
people to be a counselor and give it a
lot of time because they most of them
have full-time work and
um we obviously try and adapt our
working ways around that but um
the allowance is probably an issue
um it's it's a very difficult one to um
if I I did have the cabinet did
contemplate very heavily this time
whether or not to put it up but
unfortunately there just wasn't enough
left in the budget to do that but a
conversation that we did have and um
with them services or I had with them
Services was that we felt that we could
probably put a little bit away for the
next for the in the next budget year and
then if we did it the following year
then we could actually then result in uh
raising at least
um the basic allowance I don't know
whether the chairs need to
um gain any ground on that but the
trouble is I think it's been year on
year there there haven't been increases
for a very very long time and even if
you're just to put it up a little bit
every year at least it doesn't fall that
far behind but um it is a problem so I
thank you for your response and I look
forward to the new new councilors coming
in in May 23.
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby we all seem to be friends tonight
out here don't we
I call upon councilor Reverend Piper to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report
oh there it is Jeff the opportunity to
ruin the atmosphere
um
just a comment about if I may about the
uh
Ramsgate Town Council on the subject of
allowances Ramsgate Town Council has
managed in recent months to actually pay
itself twice the allowances allocated as
Ward grants and now also as allowances
it is a decision that's being challenged
but it is something that they've managed
to come up with under a labor
Administration
yes I'm a federal right counselor um
councilor Everett uh councilor Piper
could you explain that uh I don't think
it does but very quickly if it does tell
us how it was the question of allowances
uh Mr chairman a comment about
allowances a comment about the
efficiency of the Ramsgate Town
councilor Piper we're not here to talk
about Ramsgate Town Council
unfortunately though it may be pressing
this evening we are here to talk Fanny
Council business
so I will make that the end of that
sentence thank you Jeff first of all
then thank you leader for your report
and your comments about the situation in
Ukraine
I wonder if we might have a clear
statement regarding such things as gas
and electrical safety checks and any
other local Authority checks that need
to be made in order for householders to
become sponsors of those traveling from
the Ukraine there is a lot of comment on
social media about these things and most
people seem to be finding that they've
using the government scheme and other
ngos have come up with a sponsorship
agreement only then to fail on a
requirement of their local Authority so
I wonder if it's possible
that we could have a clear statement
from the council not this evening
necessarily but a clear communication to
all members so we know how to
communicate that to the members of the
public
it was great fun to be involved in the
Jackie Baker's event although I did
spend most of the time coughing um it
was a a very popular event it's being
well supported around the island can I
just comment I have written in about
this to the Open Spaces Ramsgate tank
out so looking to plant a lot more trees
the Avenue that's been started on Jackie
Baker's is a good start perhaps we could
have a meeting a discussion about the
possibility of continuing that Avenue
all the way around the edge of that
field
the online waste portal
um I think it will be good in the end
there are the inevitable teething
problems and I'm quite sure they will be
dealt with but for some of our residents
in Buxton Road and Highbury Gardens for
example to go six weeks without
proper Collections and then to have the
portal telling them they've been
collected when clearly they haven't it's
a real issue I wonder if you could get
the relevant team to have a look at that
please
uh the supporter counselor uh become a
council event we've been doing our best
to support that on social media having
invited several people to come I hope it
will be a successful evening and thanks
to the team for putting it on uh that
that concludes my attempt to ruin the
atmosphere Mr chairman
no you haven't ruined the atmosphere at
all councilor Piper I'm sure councilor
Ashby is delighted to respond here
thank you
thank you chair thank you councilor
Piper
yes unfortunately I can't comment on the
um
the uh allowances on at Ramsgate Town
Council
but I did enjoy my visit last night and
I was um
suitably hosted even though there wasn't
any water he put counselor Auburn did
promise me a gin and tonic but there
wasn't even there wasn't even a glass of
water
[Laughter]
um the household checks
um when the
um crisis first started I did I asked
the chief executive to set up a
dedicated page on our website which she
did organize along with the comms team
and there's lots of information on there
so therefore as the chief executive is
here listening I will ask if the comms
can actually
um
add the household check and that
procedures where
um where we where res where households
are taking in refugees
um what they need to do regarding the
checks so I'm sure she can confirm that
and it will be added to our dedicated
page that is already there
um the continuation of the tree planting
um I will pass that to our climate
emergency Cabinet member who I'm sure
will be more than happy to have the
conversation with you regarding that
um
and finally I the early teething
problems with uh with the new digital
Hub I I would imagine that any system
when you're launching it um I understand
today all the energy websites crash
because everybody was trying to enter
their meter readings for the last day of
31st because they've been told that
that's what they need to do so the whole
of the energy websites uh crashed today
so um I'm sure that there's some
sympathy with launching which what is
that are quite a revolutionary technical
hub for for our waste collection service
but of course once the teething problems
are sorted out the data will allow us to
provide an even better service than
we're already providing so thank you for
your comments and I hope that the
answers are to your liking
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby did I hear that right Council
Auburn the opposition buying drinks for
the leader perhaps not uh councilor
Garner I Turn to You For questions in
relationship
yes of course yes duplicate I I didn't
have any money on me cheers
levity tonight isn't it I call upon
councilor Garner to comment on or ask
questions in relation to the leaders
report councilor Garner thank you chair
and thank you yeah I'm sure I'm sure all
of us share the Regis horror at the
events which have unfolded in Ukraine
over the last few weeks and we welcome
seeing the Ukrainian flag flying over
our offices to demonstrate our
solidarity with the Ukrainian people in
their fight
it's also been heartening to see the
large number of people across than it
who've rallied to their cause and
collected large numbers of items to ship
out to Poland to help in the relief
we welcome the focus of on the community
throughout the rest of the report we are
indeed fortunate to have engaged an
enthusiastic communities who want to
work with the council and it's important
we do all we can to listen to and work
with our residents as much as possible
the recent tree planting events across
the district have been heartening to see
we'd like to thank all officers who've
worked hard to make sure as many trees
as possible were planted in a number of
different locations and I'm sure those
members of the community who got
involved will be Keen to watch their
trees grow and do their best to make
sure no harm comes to them
of course while it's important to plant
as many trees as possible it's equally
if not more important to make sure we do
all we can to protect those trees we
already have
too few mature trees are protected and
too many of these are being filled
because they seem to get in the way of
anything from new developments to a view
of the coastline our priorities need to
shift
those of us on the climate change
committee mentioned in the report and
chaired by Council of Bob bayford
received a stark update this week from
our climate change officer on the latest
report from the intergovernmental panel
on climate change on the urgency of
climate action and the need for keeping
the 1.5 degrees limit alive
this isn't something we can put off now
I know many officers are working hard to
make sure our action plan is kept on
track
we're pleased to see the good work being
done in King George V Park to help
reduce the serve the risk of surface
flooding
that area leading down from All Saints
Avenue and Hearthstone Road has been a
flooding hot spot for a number of years
and I know a number of agencies
including KCC and Southern water have
been working hard to improve the
situation
because they're going to need to they're
going to need to think extra hard about
the additional enhancements that will be
needed to alleviate the likely flooding
problems which are going to be caused by
the addition of a few thousand more
houses within a mile or so of that site
in Westgate and Garland if approved
it's good to hear about the tech digital
technology projects as it's important
for us to make more information readily
available to Residents online
we do of course have a high percentage
of older residents some of whom are not
confident online so we must not assume
everyone will be confident using these
and make sure we're also able to present
a friendly personal face to residents at
all times
of course whether it be online or in
person it's crucial that we always abide
by our commitment to be open and
transparent so people who pay their
council tax know what to expect and can
be confident they will get a straight
answer to a question
we're welcome to be a council of event
taking place on Thursday April the 7th
and encourage as many people as possible
who want to attend to do so
we need more people who want to actively
participate in local democracy to get
involved as that's the best way to
affect positive change across our
communities
and finally the Great British spring
clean
this is another good example of how
members of the community have come
together to take action to clean up
their neighborhood with the support of
council officers at both district and
town levels there are still a number of
litter picks planned for the next few
weeks including tomorrow morning meeting
in the station car park on Saint Peter's
Park Road at 10 A.M anyone else who
wants to join us there to keep our
neighborhood clean would be more than
welcome thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ghana I'm not sure I identified a
question there but um Council Ashby
Jewish to respond
thanks chair
yes I I agree a tree is for life it's
the easy part is the planting and I can
assure people that that is the case we
do need to um
look after these trees and
um pass them on to the next Generation
to look after and to understand it so we
have to consider that when we're
planning any planting that we can
actually maintain them for a long for a
longer period
um pleased to say uh I mean the George
the Fifth um
Suds project was was excellent and also
the Landscaping that has
come as a result of that it did take KCC
quite a long time to to get their act
together on that because of the covid
lockdown etc etc but it's actually
looking quite stunning there on that
part now and it's a it's a vast
Improvement to what it was even before
they they dug the big hole there so it's
actually proof that you can actually
come up with a really good solution and
then end up with a really nice uh design
and and an open space for a community to
go and sit in so um pleased to say that
I sit on the um I think it's called the
task force the southern water task force
they haven't had an awful lot of
meetings but
um
thanet
um have
um actually there are plans for two more
sub projects within the thanet area
um so it's quite important that when I
sit on that to obviously push us forward
for any any plans that are coming
through so
um and I thank you for for your other
comments and um I wish everybody luck
with that with their liter picking and
but it's not just it's not just the one
week is it it's all 52 weeks of the year
so I certainly you know when I go out
for a walk most days I've always got a
Dustbin uh bag in my in my hand which I
I pick up um
try and restrain the dog from actually
taking off with a plastic bottle so
yes I know but um if we all if we all
pick up five a day then we'll we'll get
there so thank you for your comments
thank you very much indeed leader
agenda item 10 the annual report of the
chair of the overview of scrutiny uh
committee now I call upon counselor
Reverend Piper who's going to present
the report councilor Piper a big moment
thank you Jeff
I've tried really hard you know I can't
get these shorter reports than than my
learned friend Council bayford over
there so you'll just have to put up me
rambling I'm afraid
um
there are a number of items that are in
the report I'm sure members are all
familiar with them the panel has been
very busy I need to thank the officers
who support us and provide us with not
just the background information we need
but with the guidance to make sure that
we're reviewing things properly I'd like
to thank all the cabinet members who've
come and presented to the panel on some
very interesting topics
and as I think I've mentioned before
already we had a visit from the police
recently which was uh quite Illuminating
but we've asked them to we're asking
them to come back and give us a little
bit more specific detail on the subject
of modern slavery
um
there is a danger I think uh members and
and I I just offer this as a kind of
course retail it's great for us to be
engaging with the public it's great for
us to be involving the public in what's
going on but sometimes it would appear
that that engagement is some it comes
across as somewhat adversarial as if
it's the public and one or two of us
against the council and it doesn't
really do us any good
um
I wonder if I could encourage members
please to look at article 6 of Planet
District council's Constitution there
are several Pages within article 6 which
give you exactly give and I include
myself in that gives us exactly the role
of the overview and scrutiny panel
exactly the decisions we can call in and
those we can't those that are something
to do with cabinet and the political
running of this Council and those that
aren't
please contact me if there's anything
that you want us to have a look at
uh but I would encourage everyone to
have a look at article 6 of The
Constitution it makes it very clear
notably the things we cannot look at
it's not within our purview uh it sounds
like I'm fighting the hard work I'm not
but it just saves the public perhaps
some members of the public they get
wound up on something before they
actually know the facts behind the
decision how it was taken why it was
taken and I believe it's our job as
councilors to try and prevent that kind
of thing happening I I commend the
report to you uh members and thank you
very much Mr chair
thank you Reverend Piper I think all of
that was very well received do members
have any comments
Council bayford
no okay
thank you members agenda item 11 the
annual report of the chair of the
standards committee I call upon Mr
Tucker to present the report please can
you make your way to the microphone Mr
Tucker
good evening chair members and officers
of the council I'm pleased to present my
second annual report which you've all
seen I have no intention of reading it
out I'm sure you've already and you're
capable of understanding it and I'm
happy to take any questions I've got no
other observations to make except
everything's running smoothly thank you
Joe
thank you Mr Tucker do members have any
questions
and I don't see anyone indicating thank
you very much indeed Mr Tucker
agenda item 12 the annual report of the
chair of the governors and audit
committee I call upon councilor boy to
present the report councilor Boyd
bear with me
um this report provides an overview of
the governance and audit committee's
activity during the municipal year 2021
to slash 22. I'm pleased to report that
the committee continues discharge its
responsibilities to provide independent
Assurance of the adequacy of the
council's risk management framework and
the associated control environment and
provides robust scrutiny and challenge
of the Authority's financial performance
as outlined in the body of this report
the committee has been actively engaged
with both internal and external audit
and I would like to thank all members
who have served on the committee during
2021. my Thanks goes to the council
officers who have supported me in my
role as chair and in the work of the
committee to assist the committee in
improving their understanding of the
council's financial accounts and
discharge its responsibility for
approving them a novel subgroup was
established with the remit of
undertaking a detailed review of the
2021-22 accounts I would like to thank
the members who fully engaged with the
input with and participated in the work
of the subgroup and the offices for
their support
this has been a difficult year with the
continuation of the pandemic and
restrictions on meeting in person
however the committee and all committees
to have overcome the challenges by
embracing virtual meetings when
necessary and meeting in person in
different venues the council has also
faced challenges this year of receiving
the statutory recommendations made by
Grant Thornton under section 24 for
local audit on accountability act 2014
work to address those recommendations is
ongoing but I am pleased that the
council has accepted the recommendation
and members of and offices are
cooperating fully with the work of the
independent monitoring officer Mr
Quentin Baker
that's it
thank you very much indeed councilor
Boyd what I thought you did very well
do members have any comments
and there are no comments thank you
gender item 13 recommendations from
standard committee questions
uh
yeah we have yes
now from I move that the recommendations
are set out in the report be adopted
with the vice chaply second second that
chair do members agree I have a
councilor Everett
thank you chair I hope we can both put
on these two proposals separately
um I have no problem with the change to
procedure or 14.6 I do have a problem
with the proposal for 14.8 not least
because it seems to me the rule would
then contain a contradiction
um I have to say that I'm a bit
suspicious of any attempt to further
limit the opportunity of members to
challenge the executive I think we
should expect our cabinet members to
have a reasonable grasp with their
portfolios and to be able to respond to
high level supplementary questions
regardless of that they have all the
power
um it's the question is who get
challenged by the chair it's not the
cabinet member making the answer uh
members are not allowed to answer back
so I don't think that the balance of
power needs tipping any further in favor
of the executive and I have sat on both
sides so I do appreciate the situation
from both sides if questions are too
technical or detailed Council will not
expect an immediate response and if
they're out of order it's already an
available chair to intervene
but in this case the proposal doesn't
even make sense
the original Amendment to the role on
supplementary questions that went to
constitutional review working group was
to add the chairman will be robust in
refusing to allow questions which do not
arise directly out of the original
question or reply the Chairman's view on
the issue will be final
now I don't see a problem with that
except for the lapse into gendered
language which we previously said we
wouldn't do
however based on what was agreed at
constitutional review working party and
standards it would Now read
the supplemental question must arise
must arise directly out of the original
question or the reply
the question must be a question and not
a statement and arise directly out of
the response
so the rule would say firstly that it
can arise solely from the original
question and then subsequently that it
must arise out of the response
frankly care this is nonsense
I'm therefore moving an amendment
and the amendment is to delete the last
seven words of the proposal and end the
addition to the rule at the word
statement
it's entirely appropriate that a
supplementary question follows on from
the original question otherwise the
cabinet member could close down an issue
by giving you a completely irrelevant
response and that cannot be right
on both grounds I asked the council to
support the amendment
thank you very much Council Everett well
we have an amendment uh tabled here are
there any other speakers at this point
yeah have I got a second for that
Council Everett I have cancer roof
does anyone wish to take that up
at a piper
thank you Jay I'd like to say that I
agree with most of what uh councilor
Everett has said when I raised my hand
earlier to
speak on on this matter
um
actually I I thought the supplementary
question would be better if it related
directly to the answer provided by the
cabinet member to whom the question was
asked rather than relating to the
original question it's kind of we we
might we might just well change it and
give people the opportunity to ask two
questions because that's often what
happens we've all seen it
um if it relates to the answer and and
to go somewhere to perhaps uh offering
some comfort to cancer ever if any
Cabinet member uh or the leader decided
to give a reply that was completely
nonsensical
um and didn't answer the original
question then the supplementary question
simply calls for a proper answer
um so it's not necessarily that
difficult and I don't think it's about
power shifting but uh
I have to say I agree with most most of
what he says I think it would be clearer
if it was a supplementary question in
response to the answer
thank you very much the council Piper
would anyone else like to speak to uh
councilor councilor bayford
yeah thank you chairman I think a lot of
this is kind of playing semantics and
but it seems to me is that Council needs
to adopt the spirit of what's meant by
this rather than worry too much about
the words because we all stuck to the
spirit of it there'd be no problem
thank you very much Council Beford do I
have any other speakers
we have an amendment Council ever could
you remind us of the wording of your
Amendment
uh yes chair so at the moment the
proposal is that the question must be a
question and not a statement comma and
arise directly out of the response and
the amendment is to delete and resp and
arise directly out of the response so we
would simply add the question must be a
question and not a statement
not yes thank you councilor Everett uh
we'll have our votes now on that since
there are no other speakers on it those
in favor
and those against
one two three four five
against and abstentions
and that is past the amendment is passed
uh so we go back to the main uh
we'll go back to the main agenda item
can we therefore have uh a member's
agreement on the um two uh procedural
changes and with the amendment
I think I'm doing this right aren't they
yes yeah so
those in favor
and those against
foreign
and any abstentions
and I think we've got
and five extensions and that is passed
thank you very much indeed members
moving on to agenda item 14
recommendations from the standard
committee revisioned to delegations I
move that the recommendation set out in
the report be adopted with the vice
chair please second a great year two
members agree
agreed
agenda item 15 oh back to Ramsgate
the Ramsgate Conservation Area appraisal
I call upon the leader councilor Ashby
thank you chair
I'm asking members and I'm seeking their
approval for the adoption of the
Ramsgate Conservation Area character
appraisal and management plan document
containing locally specific information
of the area following the public
consultation in November to December
2021 I would also like to add that I
think this is an incredibly fine
document and it would be a very good
reference point for anybody either
visiting Ramsgate or for for all of us
across the District of thanet thank you
chair so I seek your approval
thank you very much Lita do you have a
second
councilor bayford
do members agree
thank you very much indeed agenda item
16 changes committees panels and boards
with members please refer to the
supplementary agenda number one
members please note the existing
political balance on committees will
remain unchanged
thank you uh nomination of members who
serve on committees
um
group leaders do have any amendments you
would like to advise a councilor Ashby
thank you chair yes I would like to add
councilor shrub to planning as we were
run short on that I believe so Council
shrub to add to planning and add
councilor leads to overview and scrutiny
on governance and audit I will be taking
off counselor Pugh and adding counselor
Lee thank you
thank you councilor Ashby councilor
Everett
thank you chair I believe we have a
vacancy on licensing which councilor
Curry has volunteered to fill thank you
councilor Piper no changes Jeff
councilor Garner no none here over
thank you very much indeed members
well
that concludes the business of sneeze
this evening uh thank you all very much
indeed for braving the weather it's been
quite Bluey up here well I can hear it
outside good night everyone